now whether they like it or not the
Conservative Party's fate at the next
election will be closely tied to the
fortunes of the brexit party and their
leader Nigel Farage joins us now from
Westminster thank you very much for
being on the program mr. surage now I
just want to ask you about the the whip
with being withdrawn from your party
from one of your MEP s Andrew England
Kerr who's had the party withdrawn due
to irreconcilable differences regarding
a likely conflicts of interest what is
that case happened well he is an MEP but
he also is a shareholder in several
businesses and in our view one or two
other things that he's said and done as
an MEP could be seen to potentially have
brought in personal gain through his
business and that to us is just not
acceptable we made these rules very
clear to our enemies when they came so
some will say that we've acted harshly
but we want to have the highest possible
standards and we're not happy with what
he's done and you what specifically has
he done then well as I say he is acting
in a way as an MEP making comments about
a business and a product that he has a
direct financial investment in and we
think that's unacceptable okay thank you
now it looks like an election may not be
too far away are you open to some kind
of pact with the Conservatives and what
are you looking for well you know I am
of course I am and I've made this very
very clear over the last few weeks
whilst we're ready we've got six hundred
and thirty five candidates vetted
approved on the list out there now
campaigning and we're ready to fight
this election of course we are you know
and with a party that believes that a
clean break brexit because that's the
only way we can honor the referendum and
we've said that if Boris Johnson's past
he goes for a clean break then of course
we ought in those circumstances to have
a non-aggression pact and actually if
that did happen Johnson would win a very
big parliamentary majority so the answer
is yes but only if the policy is right
our concern
our deep our deep concern is that he
wants to revisit and reheat mrs. Mays
deal the new European treaty and that
just would not be brexit in fact that
would be
a surrender act I just want to pull you
up on the clean break excellent idea
it's a phrase that we hear quite a lot
it wouldn't be a clean break would it if
we leave without a deal we'll be
straight back around the negotiating
table with the EU to try and work out
the future trading relationship with our
biggest trading partner and in the
meantime they'd be disruptive disruption
there wouldn't be clean what it well I
don't buy the disruption argument at all
you know when you get the bosses of both
the ports of Calais and over saying they
are a hundred percent prepared for trade
on WTO terms because it just needs one
more piece of paperwork that I think we
shouldn't listen to the scare stories
too much and as far as doing a trade
deals concern well yes you're right of
course you know life is very easy with a
free trade deal and without quota the
problem is the Conservative government
never ever asked for it we've had three
and a quarter years on most of it under
mrs. may of attempting to Tyus very
closely to a single market and customs
union so the only way you can talk about
a sensible trade deal you know a Canada
plus plus deal or call it what you will
is first to leave men to operate on that
basis and when we're doing that of
course we won't just be talking to the
European Union we'll be talking to a
much bigger wider and in some ways much
more exciting world yeah just to go back
to the idea of a pact with the
Conservatives I can't help thinking that
the reason you're talking about a fact
is because you know that if Boris
Johnson goes into the next election
promising is no deal breaks it if
necessary the brexit party are really
going to struggle
now the Conservative Party haven't said
that they want a pact with you in fact
they said the opposite so if you
actually had any conversations about it
with them here's the point if you look
at the European elections where you know
the six-week-old party won the national
polls look where we scored the highest
we scored the highest in the northeast
of England we scored the highest in
parts of South Wales we were getting our
biggest scores in labour areas these are
parts of the country
that the Conservative Party have never
won are not going to win and yet we are
the challengers in those seats so there
is a very grown-up way of approaching
this and furthermore
you know in those marginal
constituencies there is polling evidence
that says 30% of labor leave voters
would if I said to them hold your nose
vote conservative in this election in
those marginals I could actually
personally help to swing some for Boris
another I estimate he'd have a majority
of 60 to 100 seats professor John Curtis
says it would certainly be 40 seats so
here is a way here is a way for Boris to
get a big workable majority and we can
help with that and we're happy to help
with that but it's got to be the right
policy now we know that you've felt the
pull of Westminster before are you gonna
be standing in this election
I don't feel the pull of Westminster
particularly now but yes of course I'll
stand and I will you know I will lead
the charge on behalf of the brexit party
and you know we are we're in a position
here where if we get to the 1st of
November and we haven't left the
European Union you will see support for
the brexit party rise considerably and I
do think in those circumstances we've
got a very very important role of play
so where are you gonna stand though like
I haven't I haven't said yet because
it'd be the most enormous distraction I
will wait and no I don't I don't want to
do that because what would happen is as
soon as I announce it hundreds of
thousands of pounds would be spent in
that constituency there is as we found
out in the past no electoral law in this
country that's worth a light so now I
believe it right to the end and now just
finally that's been a lot of concern in
Westminster this week about language in
political debate and whether or not it
is fuelling the abuse of MPs threats to
themselves threats their families now
and know this happens on all sides I
know that you yourself have been you
know targeted by some of this stuff
previously as well and but I just want
to have a look at something that you
said earlier this week in a speech in
Newport you've criticized overpaid
pen-pushers in Whitehall who are not
doing a neutral job and then you said
once brexit is done
we'll take the knife to them I mean is
that not if not only a deeply
inappropriate thing to say even a
dangerous thing to say well you know
you've got Labour MPs who specifically
have said they would knife Jeremy Corbyn
you've got all sorts of about what you
said yes it would have been much better
it would have been better it would would
have been better to say axe I should
have said we'll take the axe to
Whitehall because that's a more
traditional term although you can go
back to our old McMillan who was known
as Mack the Knife if you wanted to know
ax would have been a better term but
equally you could still say to me well
that's an aggressive phrase here's the
point all of this is a massive
distraction that is coming from the
remainders who want to halt the
democratic process in this country that
is what is going on here Parliament was
recalled it seemed to spend an
inordinate amount of time discussing
this subject and then they all packed up
early and went home